Então o que é Qiskit
Qiskit é um kit de desenvolvimento de software de código aberto
para trabalhar com computadores quânticos
ao nível de circuits
algoritmos e módulos de aplicação. Esse SDK
permite que qualquer pessoa programe em computadores quânticos reais a partir do
seu laptop. Com duas linhas de código você pode acessar
vários sistemas quânticos, variando de supercondutores
a qubits de íons aprisionados. Quer emular o comportamento de um computador quântico
em vez disso? Mude uma única linha de código
e simule seus quantum circuits no nosso de alto desempenho
simulador. Qiskit é uma ferramenta usada por dezenas de
milhares de pessoas ao redor do mundo, todas tentando
construir o futuro. Seja você pesquisador, desenvolvedor
ou apenas querendo começar,
Qiskit tem uma série de
funcionalidades disponíveis para as suas necessidades,
permitindo que qualquer pessoa faça coisas
como construir seu primeiro quantum circuit,
executar algoritmos quânticos de domínios cruzados
e estudar fenômenos quânticos fundamentais.
Talvez agora seja o momento perfeito para você se envolver
e encontrar todas as ferramentas que você precisa,
incluindo máquinas quânticas reais
e o SDK pelo Qiskit,
além de uma comunidade que está feliz em receber
e responder qualquer dúvida que você possa ter ao longo do caminho.
Você pode começar hoje
em qiskit